we have eight weeks of boot camp ahead
of us batsmen not working out at all
masking tape it is no friend to chilled
aluminum velcro color-coded efficient
environmentally friendly who's he
talking to
who is he dressed like a registered sex
offender can we focus for a moment
ladies because we need to talk about
next month's meal plan obviously
everyone hated this ceviche I read the
suggestion box that's on I'm gonna stop
you right there
I see through this week act you may have
fooled Colossus was this nice guy [ __ ]
but not me don't be mean bake-off NCW oh
no no no no no let her go let her go
it's okay she has a right to be
skeptical look at me I'm an easy target
you know historically mischief has been
my mistress so I understand but I like
to think that you guys have really
rubbed off I like to think that I've
rubbed off around you too lot
and for the first time in a long while I
like me I accept your apology I never
apologized I was talking to your heart
see you're not lost cause your thoughts
I'm proud you're everything I knew you
can be thank you Colossus just trying to
be the world's best x-man sorry
next person hmm something wrong with the
soap it's fine I just felt it give it a
few more pumps there now excuse me it's
dust funny season and I'm hunting
wabbits
[Music]